twitter
has a new feature it's called twitter
spaces if you remember the app clubhouse
it's kind of like that where you can log
in and have audio conversations with a
curated group of people so twitter has
just rolled this out i haven't tried it
yet but i did see when twitter rolled it
out
that
there was a trend a trending hashtag
the trending hashtag was a hashtag
male monkeys gotta go i said male
monkeys what is it and then i looked at
what was next to it
yt people deserve nothing n-u-f-f-i-n
y-t like youtube people well i agree i
do think they deserve nothing i don't
think they deserve anything
oh no it's white then i realized it's
white people white
people deserve nothing hashtag mayo
monkeys gotta go now i have always
considered myself more of an aioli
monkey i'm a little spicier and
mediterranean and very very
sophisticated but i think they were
using this term mayo monkey to refer to
all white people
take a listen to the conversation
first of all let's talk let me tell you
something if you're in here or y'all go
right back and tell them y'all got to
tell them and tell them that nobody else
said sh but me i'm going to say listen
you ain't got to chop [ __ ] up i am for
the white genocide i am for the total
erasure of the white race i you don't
have to chop this up yes i am for all of
you white dying like flies i am for it i
am for it i support it i am for putting
all you white postures in a gas chamber
and letting that [ __ ] ring
i am for it so you don't have to chop
[ __ ] up i'm for it and i'm gonna stand
ten toes down behind it
simple as that so you gotta chop [ __ ] up
you ain't gotta screw this
i set it and i stand on it
now
lest you think that this was just some
kind of random
brief exchange from a co-host of this
conversation on twitter it wasn't one of
my producers was in the conversation
live when it was happening it was the
whole conversation obviously look at the
title of it white people deserve nothing
male monkey's gotta go this was trending
on twitter
[Music]
which it would seem to contradict the
lie that we're often told and now that
children are taught in schools across
the country that black people can't be
racist
you'll hear this taught in corporate
boardrooms in classrooms all over the
place
black people
can't be racist so even if they say
something like this they're not really
racist because they're black and if
you're black you can't be racist so by
definition they're not racist even if
they're calling explicitly for the white
genocide their their words not mine and
saying we have to put white people in
gas chambers
it goes without saying i hate to even be
so cliche as to say this
that if white people did anything like
this it would be not just a an incident
on twitter not just a controversy in the
united states it would be an
international incident the u.n would be
looking into this okay
but it's not
and so
there is obviously a double standard
here and it's frankly it's not even
really worth i mention it just
so briefly for the for the handful of
people who don't see the point who don't
see the double standard
when guests come up to my door this
holiday season this is how i'm to greet
them i'm going to greet them holding up
these two gigantic knives to show off
the incredible japanese steel that they
are made with kamikoto makes great
japanese steel kitchen knives using more
than 800 years of traditional techniques
from japan each knife comes in a
beautiful wooden heavy duty box
it makes sure that the knives are stored
safely and it makes kamikodo a great
gift each kamikoto knife goes through a
rigorous 19-step process that takes
several years from start to finish to
complete the expert blade smiths forge
and shape raw steel into hardy blades
polishing it and sharpening them to an
excruciatingly fine edge each knife is
individually inspected kamikoto is so
confident about their knives that each
knife comes with a lifetime guarantee i
really strongly recommend it one it
makes you look really intimidating but
two it's just terrific in the kitchen
kamikoto is currently having a massive
christmas sale and on top of that sale
you can get an additional fifty dollars
off any purchase you make
with discount code noel's canon wles so
click the link below
or go to kamikodo.com
knowles and use promo code knowles
canadawles
to save an extra 50 bucks today
contrary to the view that is taught in
schools and in offices and hr trainings
and comes from critical race theory and
other associated movements contrary to
the idea that only white people can be
racist
all of the evidence we have available to
us
suggests that white people are the least
racist people on earth they are the
least racist people ever in the whole
history of the world
pew research
had a survey that came out just a few
years ago
showed that white people have the lowest
racial consciousness by far they asked
people who are white black asian and
hispanic how important is your race to
you
and
of the people who said that race was
somewhat or very important
you had that number over 50 percent for
asian people
over 50 percent for hispanic people over
70 percent for black people said their
races somewhat are very important to
them
only 15 for white people
shockingly low racial consciousness
there's another survey survey just came
out from rasmussen
that said that 37
of american adults
believe that black people
hold racist views
as opposed to just 15
who who believe that white people hold
racist views
now you might say well that's just
because i don't know there were a lot of
white people pulled but it's not true
even among only the black people polled
the black people believed that black
people were more racist than white
people 31 of the black people surveyed
by rasmussen said that they considered
people of their own race to be racist
while only 24 of them thought that white
people were racist so we're not saying
that white people are not at all racist
or that black people are completely 100
racist but all of the data we have
suggests that white people are the least
racist people in the history of the
world in fact
the very concept of racism the very idea
that racism might be a bad thing comes
from
white people
that's
just look at the history of the ideas
so
the idea that uh that only whites can be
racist is as
we see from social science as we see
from various twitter conversations
perfectly divorced from reality
okay it's and you see this a lot in our
culture increasingly so
maybe the most obvious version of this
is that is transgenderism the idea that
men are really women and if you say that
they're not you're
you know you have to be silenced
if you contradict this obvious delusion
that is totally divorced from reality
but you see this on issues of
sex
race economics
politics
everywhere you are seeing a chasm
opening up
between the official narrative that the
establishment tells us
and reality
and this is a very
scary thing
because things do not end well when your
society is divorced from reality let's
take this beyond the racial issues and
the mayo monkeys having to go and the
sex even just broadly if your society
is grounded on
delusion
your society is not going to flourish
when you look around us right now and
you see society crumbling in basically
every sector and you and you see the
people running our society have
extremely low approval ratings rightly
so
you you see the consequences of that
delusional kind of ideology i'm glad you
like that clip now i need you to ring
the bell
i need it i need it i don't ask for very
much do i no i don't
just gotta ring that bell you get the
notifications if you don't get the
notifications because of our friends at
big tech
then maybe head on over to apple podcast
spot if i stitch your google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
subscribe
maybe leave a five star review
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you